this is like one of the great moments in
modern science I really think it is it's
it's certainly the moment that people
who know who Dick Alexander was
reference as sort of the high-water mark
because it's it's comprehensible you
know dick did a lot of things he was
very interested in people and other
things but this particular demonstration
was so it would be impossible to have
predicted such a thing and have gotten
lucky now Dick Alexander is a legend in
evolutionary theory because it it's very
hard to use evolutionary theory to make
predictions that can be verified in the
world it's it's sort of like this loose
amorphous collection of techniques and
viewpoints and people sometimes think
it's not even a theory because it
doesn't seem to be predictive and then
there are a few predictions so am i
right Darwin started this game off by
predicting that there would be a moth
with a really long tongue because there
was a flower that had a really long
distance to go before you could get the
nectar out of it yeah he had been sent
an orchid by Bateson maybe with a foot
long Carola tube and he reasoned very
straightforwardly that it would make no
sense for this plant to have invested in
this very long structure if there were
not a tongue that could reach down to
gather the nectar and I believe he did
not live to see the discovery of that
animal I'd know that but he he was
absolutely correct there is a moth that
has this beautifully long tongue it's a
spinning hawk moth one of these sort of
hummingbird esque moths and anyway yeah
it's one of the major predictions
demonstrations that evolution core
theory actually can be used to predict
phenomena that you haven't been able to
observe okay and you know Darwin
famously couldn't for example like I
don't know how much I've talked about
this in the open but my favorite Darwin
book is the one he wrote after Origin of
Species which is on the various
contrivances by which British and
foreign orchids are fertilized by
insects it makes absolutely no sense as
a title because I think that's
so funny about it and but because
orchids are so highly speciated turned
out to be the perfect place to explore
the consequences of evolution and he
couldn't figure out my favorite I don't
whether it's clade or group I it's
pretty safe
yeah clade of orchids the ophrys system
which is just unbelievable because it
mimics the pollinators the female of the
pollinator species using pheromone
pheromones and some sort of replica good
enough to fool males into copulating
with the lower petal of of an orchid
it's a sturdy replica of the female that
smells like her and it just so happens
that when the male lands on it to
copulate he gets these pollen packets
glued to him and then he screws up and
makes the same mistake at another flower
and don't leave me he may or may not put
it this but only the ones that screw up
twice get to get to fertilize the reason
that it gets glued to him is that it has
worked enough times for this strategy to
have been so beautifully refined right
so Darwin saw there was this mimicry
going our bee couldn't put it together
you split the pages and pages not
getting it so I think it's very funny so
he predicts some things but he can't
predict something else in a very closely
related system okay fast forward Dick
Alexander comes out with a crazy
prediction which I still don't fully I
mean it's just amazing that he made it
where he says I bet that you will find
the kind of behavior we associate with
wasps and bees which is in this clay
called hymenopteran dance of you social
breeding patterns in an organization but
in mammals that will live underground so
I think the way this story actually
worked he didn't say you will find or
you could find what he said is in
principle there's no reason that a you
social animal has to be an insect that
in fact you could get such a thing in a
mammal and then he predicted I forget
how many characteristics there were but
he named some words that there's
something funny about the system of ants
bees wasps which is that they've got
this very strange haploid chromosomal
characteristic do I say a word about
that because I'm
the prediction more sure so it has long
been understood that the Hymenoptera
behaved in this incredibly cooperative
fashion in which effectively all of the
workers of the colony forego
reproduction in order to advance the
reproductive interests of the queen and
it was late discovered that actually
their genetic system is unlike our
genetic system and that males have
basically half a full complement of
genes they have enough greens to
function but they have half the female
complement of genes and for reasons that
are mathematically slightly complicated
and require a chalkboard the females are
more closely related to the daughters
produced by their mother than they would
be to their own offspring their
three-quarters relatives to her
offspring in there they would be 50%
relatives to their own office Avada so
they are actually evolutionarily favored
by very standard mechanisms once you
understand the crazy genetics underlying
the thing they are favored to engage in
behavior where they forego reproducing
and positive once you understand the
chromosomal difference of this system it
is far less surprising that it would
behave as a loosely coupled in some way
don't over don't overreact unified
organism which is distributed that there
is a way in which and there are ways in
which the hive behaves as a super
organism and there are ways in which it
does not
yeah well all I want to say is I'm not
sure how clear we have the story with
respect to what precedes what it's
completely plausible that the behavior
precedes the evolution of the genetic
system right and I actually frankly just
don't know where that research stands at
the moment we have found many other
insect systems that have various
versions of this interestingly though
the termites are not hymenopteran right
and the termites engage in this behavior
you know it's our eusocial but they're
not applicable they're you socially
behaved very much like ants okay but
they don't have the strange genetic
system proving that the behavior can
involve even in the absence of this
genetic system well the reason I bring
this up is that if you if you look at
for example
peter kropotkin the great anarchist
theorist he was obsessed by finding
analogues in nature of preferred human
structures and so it's very simple to
say why can't we work together the way
an ant colony all works together and
then there's a counter to that which is
well they have different chromosomal
structures and then you say well but yes
but that's a kind of a cheap way of
achieving eusociality there are other
ways of it so we threw this crazy kind
of investigation we get to dick
Alexander who and I think you're quite
quite correct says there is nothing
prohibiting us from finding a mammalian
species that exhibits ant and wasp like
behavior and it would have it would be
likely to have these characteristics it
would live underground and uh yeah
underground believe eating tubers was a
it was a crazy list raising and you know
my understanding from from dick dick is
now unfortunately dead he died a couple
of years ago but my understanding from
him was that he didn't actually expect
to find such an animal he was speaking
very absolutely just completely
theoretically and at the point that he
unleashed this idea it may even have
been in a talk rather than a paper the
information made it back to him actually
what about naked mole-rats they match
your characteristics and study reveals
then that actually they are you social
they behave very much like ants bees
wasps termites etc and this is like one
of the great moments in modern science I
really think it is it's it's certainly
the moment that people who know who dick
Alexander was reference as sort of the
high-water mark because it's it's
comprehensible you know did a lot of
things he was very interested in people
and other things but this particular
demonstration was so it would be
impossible to have predicted such a
thing and have gotten lucky he had to
have understood some things that were
extremely deep in order for that to have
worked out and so yeah it's really I
don't know of another example in in
in evolutionary theory of a prediction
that clean of something that obscure I
know one oh yeah yeah I once heard a
story about a a graduate student who
predicted that the breeding protocols of
laboratory rodents would compromise the
laboratory system in terms of its
relationship to so-called wild-type
versions of the same species so you have
the bred rodents and you have the wild
rodents and that they would be
distinguished by virtue of the fact that
the non-coding nucleotide sequence at
the end of the chromosome known as
telomeres would be wildly different in
length
if the prediction were true from pure
evolutionary theory Wow
yeah yeah yeah that story it didn't
happen exactly the way you said it but
you know it's been a lot of years and
well they're gonna get back there yeah I
mean it's you you did that yeah I did
that
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]